eigentlich heißt es entweder islam islam
also ich mach poetry slam oder eben
islam
wir treten ja auch bewusst mit einer
islamischen identität auch also mit
einer muslimischen identität wir es auch
hauptsächlich in ein parlament projekt
für muslimische künstler dazu kommt noch
eben die ganze geschichte mit ipad
iphone ipod ist natürlich so für
werbetechnik war das natürlich für uns
nur von großem vorteil
es gibt halt probleme in der
gesellschaft gewisse vorurteile die die
man die den muslimen vorgeworfen werden
da ist jetzt gewalt in jeglicher form
mit frauen oder andersdenkenden oder
sowas mitteilt
das war auch ein absoluter antrieb für
uns zu sagen okay wir schaffen jetzt
eine bühne wo wir sagen da kommt die
muslime mal zu wort die jungen muslime
sie haben auch eine ganze menge zu sagen
und jeder der interesse daran hat zu
erfahren was also wie es eigentlich in
summe muslimischen jugendlichen in
deutschland oder halt auch in der
schweiz und österreich
was so in dem vor geht der kann einfach
mal zum einsatz kommen und sich das
anhören
alle
meinetwegen kannst du patriotisch und
auch europäisch sein und nennen auch
ruhig das abendland sein du musst mir
auch kein stück von deinem kuchen
abgeben denn letztlich und damit musst
du leben seit der morgensonne ist es nun
auch eine fata morgana deinen abendland
und solltest du schützen nach der
illusion greifen wirst du merken dass
dieser kuchen nie bestand
und ich glaube du musst nicht mehr
traurig sein mama ich glaube ich bin
syrischer als ihr weiter immer dachten
denn irgendwo muss es doch herkommen was
ich panische angst habe vor polizisten
dass ich paranoid werde wenn mir jemand
mehr als zwei fragen stellt also als mal
blut mal deine tochter trägt einen
brocken syrischen sich herum
bleibt nur die frage was man eigentlich
macht wenn man merkt dass man etwas
liebt erst in dem moment als zerstört
wird
wir möchten einerseits nichtmuslime
erreichen um ihn eben diese gedankenwelt
eines muslimischen menschen näher zu
bringen möchten aber auch muslime
erreichen weil wir auch viele
muslimische konflikte ansprechenden
texten viele unserer slam-poeten
befassen sich auch mit solchen themen
wie zum beispiel terror dies das und
jenes oder auch kopf durch aus einer
muslimischen perspektive
die zerstrittenheit der muslime aus
einer muslimischen perspektive wir
fassen uns damit ist auch wichtig dass
muslime im publikum sitzen sie auf eben
diese sache mit kriegen
angst angst angst die welt hat angst
deutschland hat angst
welcher idiot hat diese bombe gebaut ist
setze dich groß genug
soll ich die letzten noch größer machen
oder weißt du nicht nur eine form gebaut
du bist zu dumm um zu leben damals
musste er kann keine bombe war
hier kann keine bonbons com da müssen
wir was machen 99 99 999 prozent aller
muslime weltweit können nicht richtig
bomben bauen
helfen sie uns die 100 zu erreichen in
erster linie für gott das ist ja das ist
eine pflicht gott in santos als
statthalter um die welt zu bewahren und
nicht um sie kaputt zu machen